did you know that the bats in Elden ring
can sing or at least they could once in
the network test files of Elden ring is
unused animation 702 which places the
bats in this upright pose singing this
mysterious song
[Music]
when this was discovered the question
quickly became what language is this
because while it sounds distinctly
Japanese it's not it's actually ainu a
language that is considered to be
critically endangered with just 304
people within Japan able to understand
the language to some extent
so even you hearing this is just such a
rare sound and while it might have
always been nothing more than a
placeholder song I'm glad that we can
all share in this song called header
tune and sung by the late umeko Ando the
singing bat was Unearthed by renowned
modest sakuro dubi and I highly
recommend their cut content videos links
in the description as always if this
song was always just intended to be a
placeholder then it was intended to be a
placeholder for the song of lament which
is a song in Latin that did make it into
the final version of the game
unlike other excerpts of Latin that
feature in Boss soundtracks in from
software games this song sung by the
harpies is completely translatable with
lyrics that tell us a story these
hobbies are actually singing alas that
Land once blessed now has diminished we
betrothed destined to be mothers now
become tarnished we have lamented and we
have shed tears but no one consoles us
golden one at whom were you so angry
so that land is obviously a reference to
the lands between and the remaining
lines are referring to the harpies
themselves though they have now lost
Grace they longed at one point for
betrothal and motherhood their cries in
the final line are for the golden one
who could be America or the greater will
that once blessed the lands between the
harpies now wonder what they've done to
deserve such a lamentable fate again
most of from software's soundtracks use
excerpts of Latin resulting in this
untranslatable soundtrack language as
confirmed by the composers themselves in
the past the song of lament is a clear
exception however and it being written
in actual Latin points to its
significance special thanks to YouTuber
and Latin student Antonius tertius for
their detailed and reliable breakdowns
of Latin in from software's games
so the harpies not being able to be
mothers is one thing but if we go back
to the network test of Eldon ring we
learn of other things that might stand
in the way of reproduction in the lands
between let's talk about the old
description of turtle neck meat
originally turtle neck meat was supposed
to boost virility but none in the lands
between seem to have much appetite for
it these days in lands between the urge
to reproduce has waned long ago and
while the description has since been
changed it does suggest that the urge
for reproduction is long dead amongst
all tarnished but I guess they were all
made unless anyway right there is some
evidence that both is now handled by the
Earth tree but that discussion might
have to wait for another video so for
now pickle your total neck meat and
consider doing something more productive
with that stamina boost
the tarnished can after all cook up some
pretty good stuff in Olden ring unlike
me the next secret is I can't I can't
cook unless it's with hellofresh so if
you don't know hellofresh is this
subscription service that provides you
with pre-proportioned ingredients right
to your doorstep meaning less prep for
you and less wasted food as well as soon
as you've signed up with the link below
you can open the app and choose your
menu for the coming week here you can
choose from a really wide range of
options and then you can upgrade your
meals or even customize your box by
adding or swapping out certain proteins
the recipes are pretty foolproof and
many meals are designed to be ready in
30 minutes or less with instructions so
clear I could even manage to cook and
film at the same time this week I chose
four meals I chose a Caesar style pork
burger roast chicken with creamy
peppercorn sauce a quick chorizo and
zucchini pasta and the smoked cheddar
beef burger so if you're Keen to learn
how to cook some meals that look like
this please use my link or go to
hellofresh.com and use code POG video
OCT 65 for 65 off plus free shipping on
your first box so prepare to fry and
let's get back to the video
speaking of talented chefs let's talk
about Black Guard big Bogart despite his
title blackguard he doesn't actually
belong to any black guard company or
order he's not a professional Knight or
a guard of anything which fits his
character given how he accosts Rya and
steals her necklace but perhaps therein
lies the answer the name blackguard is
actually the word blaggard in the
Japanese version of the game which is
another word for scoundrel or one who
uses foul language in front of a
respectable woman which marrick is tit
yeah that tracks chat with him though
and this tough exterior begins to melt
away but we'll talk more about Bogarts
in the upcoming prepare to cry episode
be a shame if anything were to happen to
him right speaking of foreshadowing
Elden ring foreshadows events right away
from the very first step looking out
from here you'll notice several key
landmarks that hint at what's to come
the most obvious is stormvale Castle and
then of course the urge tree but there's
a third Landmark that only recently
noticed that Towers even further in the
distance the forge housing the Giant's
flame it's here where you'll fight the
fire Giant and ignite one of the most
important flames in your Eldon Ring
Journey but catching a clear glimpse of
it from the first step is pretty
difficult even with the telescope
however you can increase the telescope's
magnification for a better look with the
help of the arrows reach Talisman which
brings me to my next secret that the
arrows reach Talisman increases the
range of your bows and crossbows and yes
your binoculars as well but that's not
all you'd be forgiven for not knowing
this but it also increases the range of
rock sling
great oracular bubble
Ambush shard
and it even affects some ashes of War
like spectral Lance and beasts rule
and as you just saw some of these
actually become a fair bit more viable
with this Talisman that's more than can
be said for most of the crossbows and
Bows which just have terrible scaling in
general and limited viability Beyond
luring enemies to you
you loot this Talisman above the gate
front sight of Grace actually from here
we can just see box hiding place and I'd
like to talk about him a little bit more
since it's unlikely he will feature in
any upcoming episodes as we've mentioned
before armor alteration has a cost if
you perform it at a sight of Grace but
it can be performed for free by Bach and
if you want to keep Bok around for the
entire game then it's important not to
give him a larval tear when he requests
one in Lane Dell doing so will send him
down an unfortunate deadly path a fate
that is actually foreshadowed earlier in
his questline if given the larval tier
Bach will make his way to rinala where
he'll be reborn in human form but unable
to speak and if you reload the area
you'll then find him dead curled up in a
corner this position is foreshadowed in
one of the earliest conversations with
bok where after reclaiming his sewing
needle he reminisces about his mother my
mum was a seamstress and that sewing kit
was all I had to Remember by
always wanted to be just like sweet old
mum
pose I I can't just curl up and die can
I
the level tier unfortunately doesn't
have the same rebirthing effect on him
as it does on you the great Rune of The
Unborn holds a warning of this as well
with its description reading children
born Anew by Ronaldo are all frail and
short-lived so when the time comes and
he asks for a level tier it's worth
using a prattling paint item instead to
tell him how beautiful he is
thank you very much mum was always the
only one who said I was beautiful and
now my dear Lord let me hear her voice
do you feel the same way my mum did my
Lord do you think I'm beautiful despite
these looks
my Lord
my dear Lord I balk the seamster I'm
forever in your service May the Throne
of Eldon Lord be yours
sometimes it's easy to overlook these
smaller items and the impact they can
have on the world around you the crystal
darts are another example of this in a
previous video we discussed how the herd
tree burial Watchdogs and imps short
circuit went struck with them attacking
each other in the process but did you
know that the giant Golems also
experience this effect they take a few
more hits than imps or burial Watchdogs
do but they will turn on each other just
the same given the crystal darts
description which reads a Golem crafter
employed a similar Crystal tool it
appears that the giant Golems have the
same Creator as the imps and the burial
Watchdogs perhaps this Golem crafter
wanted an easy way to keep them all
controlled and could do so through these
darts
mogot's cursed sword is another
interesting item its description reads
accursed blood that more got recanted
and sealed away reformed into this blade
it also has quite the introduction as
morgot reveals its iridescent design by
breaking the outer shell of his Cane
however this reveal has undergone a bit
of a change in recent patches originally
in patch 1.02 this animation featured
Flames Rippling through the cracks of
his Cane which is a detail that suited
him remarking how you're emboldened by
the flame of ambition but this has since
been removed as pointed out by a user on
Reddit since patch 1.04 the Flames have
disappeared and the outer shell of his
Cane now just crumbles away this change
is minor but I don't think it's a bug I
think it's intentional by removing the
flame it actually holds back the reveal
of what this sword is capable of which
actually takes place in the second phase
not the first phase its unique skill is
cursed blood slice which leaves this
bloody Trail followed by a burst of
flame and taking away this foreshadowing
gives this weapon a chance to show off
what makes it special in the fight
itself
this look of Madness is one that's only
seen in select locations in Olden ring
but it is easily recognizable through
glowing flame-like eyes you can even
give your character These Eyes by
pursuing the Lord of frenzy flame ending
and the moment you get these eyes is
when you're embraced by the three
fingers these eyes are actually only one
of three different variations that you
can give your character though blood red
eyes are another option that appear once
vare's questline has been completed and
Dragon Eyes appear after purchasing four
separate Dragon communion incantations
if you find these aren't your style or
you remove them accidentally can enable
or disable These Eyes through the mirror
in fear's room these eye colors just
scratch the surface of what Eldon ring
offers in terms of customization to help
figure out players favorites Japanese
magazine famitsu conducted a survey with
1 700 Elden ring players back in April
this covered everything from bosses to
weapons to which locations were players
favorites so despite the wide variety of
weapon types available katana's won over
841 of these 1700 players that's almost
half the votes and it does make sense
considering how coveted the moonvale and
rivers of blood are and there's rarely
been a bad Katana in a Souls game after
all greatswords came in close behind
with 641 votes for magic users ComEd
Azure was a Top Choice of attack with
240 votes again this makes sense with
how unbeatable it can be when stacked
with the right Buffs and you might be
wondering which Spirit ashes took the
prize it's not surprising to learn that
the mimic tier was at the top of the
list but black knife tiege as well came
in at a close second
as for bosses star Scourge Redan left
the greatest impact on players with 687
votes and perhaps unsurprisingly
Millennia came in just behind him as 658
as for endings rani's ending is by far
people's favorites and Caleb and Lim
grave came out on top in regards to
areas with 456 and 409 votes
respectively
that every location in Eldon ring
contains hidden details and even now I'm
still noticing new things when I explore
the world just tucked away in a piece of
map that I've somehow missed until now a
perfect example lies here in a
northwesterly area of the Altus Plateau
here you might have noticed an unusual
concentration of death-blighted
creatures as well as a minor herd tree
that is completely dead with a small
gathering at its base the spread of this
death blight is actually due to the
location that Lies Beneath all of this
the deep root depths it's here where
Godwin the prince of death is rotting
away slowly his death route has started
to make its way through the lands
between which explains why creatures
both above and below can be seen with
his posturals of death especially the
closer they are to Godwin's throne it's
these small details that really make
Elden Ring's world and story and these
kind of details can also be plucked out
of cutscenes one Reddit user credit to
them found one very important detail
during Godfrey's cutscene it's that
there is actually a guidance of Grace in
this scene that is directing him towards
you as his next objective the most
important detail in this scene actually
ties into where this grace is coming
from morgot's body as Godfrey sets him
down and he dissolves the guidance then
points him to his next purpose defeating
you for number 15 let's talk about
patches Everyone Knows by now that he
disappears when summoned for the fight
against radon it's funny and it suits
the cowardice inherent in his character
which was set up earlier when he begs
for Mercy against you but did you know
that you can later beg for mercy against
him if you attack patches and he he
manages to lower your health to half he
tells you to grovel instead doing so
grants you the extreme repentance
gesture and once performed he says he'll
forgive you and considers your
transgression of water under the bridge
this is quite a fun way to show that
even though he's deceitful and insincere
patches actually has the ability to be
reasonable it's also a moment where you
can pick up another gesture so don't
miss it
one thing you might have missed is
located here at the stargazes ruins in
the mountaintops of the Giants here
aureliet is searching for her sister
Aurelia
stuff
where did you go
promise me when we turn 14. we got to
see the stars
I've been waiting tonight for so long
forever and ever it seems
and if you've spoken to roderica then
Aurelia has actually been traveling with
you this whole time the spirit jellyfish
roderica gave you back then is Aurelia
proven by her description which also
reads that she's a jellyfish prone to
tears who is searching for her distant
home
reuniting the two sees them setting off
to see the stars but the moment is made
Bittersweet by the truth of what
actually happened to them of course
they're both spirits and if you continue
down the cliff side Beyond The Ruins
you'll find two small Graves it would
seem that the sisters died young with
their one final wish being to see the
stars I'm not sure why they couldn't see
the stars before this maybe they
belonged to the Knox who were banished
down to the Eternal cities and they only
just made their way up here but
regardless thanks to you it seems they
are finally able to be at peace another
interesting character who can give you
their Spirit ashes is Latina who is an
albanoric woman who longs to return to
the land of mikola's halik tree and
interestingly this spirit is actually
able to mount other nearby direwolves in
special circumstances just like the
other albenoric wolf back archers in the
game use a neopi on Reddit made this
discovery showing how Latina's Spirit
Ash can ride direwolves in both carrier
Manor and the consecrated snow fields so
not only does this allow her to move
around much quicker but she can also
cast freezing Mist while mounted this is
also a completely unique Behavior to
Latana Kaiden Spirits can't ride Kaiden
horses nor can knock Spirits Riot giant
ants like their actual counterparts
in-game can according to zuly the witch
this might occur because the albanoric
archers can't move so wolves have to be
coded to go to them thus the Wolves
actually are the ones with the ride
request functions in their logic but the
Knox ants and the Kaiden horses do not
have this by comparison
for number 18 did you know that gostock
is actually one of Elden Ring's
sneakiest and most deceptive NPCs from
the moment you meet him this character
is actually following you around
stormvale Castle unseen and while he's
doing this he is stealing 30 percent of
the runes that you get in this area each
time you die but lucky for you there's a
few ways to stop this Rune tax from
occurring you can of course kill gostock
which also Nets you his Bell bearing but
then you miss out on the ancient dragon
smithing stone that he grants you at the
end of his questline if you'd prefer to
stop him in a less permanent fashion you
can actually catch him stalking you
around the castle you can find him
following you here at the very bottom
floor below the door that needs the
rusty key
here and next to the rampart Tower Grace
in the tower behind you and here on the
rooftop above where you first meet
regier talking to him in these locations
puts an end to his meddling and ensures
that you can keep all of your runes
gostock actually has a couple of aspects
around him that are easy to overlook
like his missing hand for example the
most likely explanation of this is that
he was grafted in the past considering
how he's living in the home of godric
the grafted after all this would make
sense and his hatred of godric points to
this as well it's clear that gostock's
no stranger to grafting but there are
moments where it sounds like he almost
wants to do it to others when following
you around stormvale particularly at his
second location you'll find him crouched
near a dead body saying another one
another one all skin and bones
worse than a petty Squier
not a muscle on this one either once you
begin talking to him he'll explain that
ah he's just clearing out some corpses
and it could be that he's just looting
these bodies but the focus on muscle is
an interesting detail this Theory can be
pushed a bit further if you attack him
early on and let him kill you
going back to Elden Ring's closed
Network test it actually has a couple
more interesting Secrets within it that
were sadly left on The Cutting Room
floor so long ago one very interesting
thing involves Ronnie the witch who
second odubi was able to discover
originally had a double voice to match
her double face what do you think of
this voice Recreation
Steed do you think this is better than
Ronnie's regular Voice or is it too much
there were several other changes made
between the closed Network test and the
full release including an important
change made to the description of the
datacars woe Talisman in the final
version of Elden ring data cars woe
describes a woman named dadica who
indulged in every form of adultery and
wicked pleasure imaginable giving birth
to a myriad of grotesque children
originally though dataka was described
as an entirely different character early
a text describes them as a soft featured
man who was one of Captain reichardt's
paramours as well as an attendant in his
Inquisition
considering this Talisman is dropped by
Ryan its current iteration befits her
backstory as this poor unwanted
offspring of a repellent birthing ritual
per the Serpent's amnion perhaps Raya
was even one of these grotesque children
the description mentions
another minor change made to a character
Was the removal of radon's pet cat the
long tail cat description found in
version 1.0 of the game featured a
description reading approach depicting a
long-tailed cat known to be the Beloved
pet of General radon it goes on to say
that this black cat was known to have
enjoyed jumping down from Great Heights
it would leap from the great Bell Tower
of Raya lucaria as a kitten and once
fully grown from the great heavensward
roots that Twisted through the urge tree
Capital Skies unfortunately this
description has been edited out for some
reason but even though official word of
radon's cat is kind of gone this small
detail helps to paint this grander
picture of the Conqueror of the Stars
along with the love that he clearly has
for his horse it seems that before his
life as an Elden ring boss he was simply
an animal lover
speaking of animals there's a piece of
grunks storyline that's very easy to
miss after receiving a few death route
he lashes out at you and after that at
some point there's even a moment where
you might catch him howling at the night
sky outside or perhaps given his
Direction maybe he's howling at the
Earth tree of course garank or malacath
was America's Shadow and it's kind of
heartbreaking to think that he's howling
in her Direction here imprisoned as she
is inside the earth tree for number 24
let's talk about Sir Gideon of near
during your battle with him he utilizes
a ton of spells and incantations but
have you ever wondered how he gets all
these spells well YouTuber Garden of
eyes explains that there's actually a
default set of spells that Gideon has
Comet commit Azure carrion Phalanx black
flame ritual triple rings of light law
of causality and one open slot this open
spot is determined by whether or not
you've killed reichardt Melania or Moog
the Lord of blood which are all optional
bosses and depending on which one of
these that you've killed reichardt's
Rancor millennius Scarlet Ionia or moogs
blood Boon can be placed in that open
slot if you've killed two of these
bosses then one of their abilities will
replace Comet Azure and killing all
three will also replace triple rings of
light and for our final secret Gideon
isn't the only boss that relies on
others for his attacks one of the
ancestral Spirits also utilizes the
smaller animal spirits that roam around
the Boss Arena to mix up its attack
patterns as pointed out by Zully the
witch the ancestral spirit will move
through the room bursting through
different animals to restore health and
obtain some of their characteristics for
example if it absorbs a deer then it
gains an upwards antler thrust absorbing
a bore grants it the ability of a
ramming charge while spring hairs give
it a jumping Stomp and the goats provide
these rolling attacks I love this detail
and so many of the details in this video
thank you so much for watching special
thanks also to hellofresh for sponsoring
this video you guys will like I think
what I've been investing some of this
sponsor money into soon with the next
prepare to cry you'll see some of that
so please do check out the link in the
description for hello fresh it really
does help me out and I'm glad I found a
couple of sponsors that I actually have
a history with using even before they
approached me so thank you so much for
the support and I'll see you next time